do you do foot stuff yeah yeah yep I uh
I suck toes okay and I like my toes
sucks and uh I love giving foot jobs
okay I've never given my life like I'm
not talking about one anymore this is
like my own personal it like when okay
cuz I've never done we had a foot guy on
here a couple episodes ago my feet I'm
saving my feet for marriage is their
foot foreplay do you slowly seductively
take your socks off do you hand them a
card that says Circle yes or no then you
come back do you foot job to
completion slugs Happy New Year I have
three shows left on this tour this month
January 7th that's this week in San Jose
January 18th in Portland and then I'll
be in Seattle January 26th you can get
tickets at esteron ice.com hey sluggy I
can't wait to meet you I can't wait to
perform for you my set is so good if I
say so myself a little cocky but I think
I've earned it come see me you can see
me next January 12th and 13th in
Edmonton you can see me February 16th
and 17th in Denver Colorado um doing
Annie wood and Friends February
20th um February 21st and 22nd I'm in
Vancouver March 1st and 2nd I'm in Fort
Worth Texas I will be in albaquerque New
Mexico I'm coming back to New Mexico
guys I'm so excited that's March 8th and
9th um at the end of March I'll be in
Washington DC and May 9th I will be in
Los Angeles at the Netflix fil uh the
Netflix is a joke festival and then in
June end of June I will be in
Jacksonville Florida I'm sorry I had to
change those dates and you can see me
every Thursday on
annwood you guys welcome back to trash
Tuesday happy New Year it's New Year
baby 2024 um this is our first episode
of 2024 so we're very excited to be
ringing in the new year with a guest
we've been wanting for a really long
time please welcome every girls girl
crush Chloe Cherry here she is thank you
so gorgeous thank you hotter and person
person wow hotter in person no we were
just saying that like in comedy we don't
really meet people as good-looking as
Chloe so we're like really intimidated
and just like excited you know she's
like a foreign creature is it's a
creature we're not used to seeing but
wouldn't you say there are infinitely
more attractive female comics than there
are men yeah and we're allowed to be we
have to be yeah yeah really not by
choice it's almost like nine out of 10
really wait explain like CU I it's so
hard to come by a good look like I'm
they're all fogos did you just watch
star Ros special is that what this is
I'm just kidding I love you st of the
male Comics iot yes to banging you on
would you bang him before anyone was
following no I have Vibes with starros
but you already know I like I like them
portly pleasantly plump and
mustached I love them mustache mustach
andl grow a mustache it's like a cop
thing it's fun oh yeah For Me Maybe yeah
Chloe was saying that she's ugly for
porn yeah that like I was like ugly for
porn and I was really ugly for Runway
modeling and really fat for Runway
modeling no maybe fat but not ugly all
models are ugly no you're so hot and
runway models are if you look at them
you're like oh something's like a like
there's like a like an alien feature
yeah they definitely have alien Vibes
yeah especially if it's like super high
fashion right like I can't like you know
just being very like um prototypically
like pretty and symmetrical I just feel
like it's like not interesting anymore
right you're so right I mean not to like
on like these gorgeously perfect
specimens but I don't find that they
like they keep my interest like for very
long do you think classic surgery is
ever going to become like people getting
filler in just one side of their face
and like try I think you should be
73 do like a jacked like make yourself
look as asymmetrical instead I mean look
I was born with beautiful asymmetry so
maybe this is my era wait so Chloe so
you like kind of started your
entertainment career in porn and then
you were cast on Euphoria and so now you
you're acting exclusively I saw you
doing some indie films but and so are
you done with porn yeah I haven't shot a
porn scene in over two years like I
haven't been anywhere near the porn
industry in over two years I haven't
been to Like a Porn event I haven't shot
a scene I haven't like posted a nude
like I haven't like done anything sex
work related was that a long
deliberation or was it like you woke up
and you're like I think I'm done with
this honestly it was just because of the
fact that like I believe that like sex
work wasn't going to last for forever
for me so I was like I might as well get
out now rather than like you know
eventually get to a point where like I'm
just not able to like make money the
same way I did at first and like I just
wouldn't want to be like I didn't want
to be like scrambling at some point you
know I just figured I might as well just
like make the transition when I got the
chance to you know and also like porn is
like um it's super fun but like it's
just very like physical like I don't
know like I was having sex last night
and I was like damn I forgot how like
hard porn was to like perform and you
did extreme things like you did gang
bangs you did like I mean deep thr stuff
I can
honestly like giant like Mandingo I
don't know knows who that is but like
big yeah like really like good at D
there and uh I loved it and it was so
cold to perform it was so cool for
people to be like whoa wowzers like you
have any do you have any like bloopers
of you just like throwing up on giant
ROM those are not bloopers they like
that actually yeah they like that cuz I
remember there was like I think two
scenes where I did that and they were
like yo this is so hot they're going to
love this and I was like okay cuz
usually like I would if I was going
going to do like a sucking thing I would
try to eat something like an apple
before something that doesn't look as
gross being thrown up in my opinion I
balone or something yes exactly nothing
like red color
um yeah and then like uh the the gang
bangs were also like really cool and
like they were just like craziness and
like I don't know sometimes I look back
on that and I'm just like wao like young
people are like so horny cuz like I just
don't know if like I could keep up with
my old self that way and like there's
plenty of like you you guys had Angela
White on and like she to this day is
like she's been performing for so many
years and she still does like all the
hardcore stuff but like I just feel like
I'm just so like unlike athletic you
know like I'm not athletic enough to
like do porn for that long I guess I
don't know what it it's just I couldn't
my body just like I couldn't keep up
with that like cuz it is like it's like
a sport it's like that makes sense to me
cuz there's a there's a boxer his name
is Lennox Lewis and I always always
admired him because when when he won the
heavyweight title he was like I'm done
with this like I'm not going to wait for
another dude to completely like brain
damage me like I'm at the top of my game
but I kind of understand that because
like porn like this I mean the hardcore
it's like it's one thing to do a sweet
little like oh I my stepbrother kind of
the stuff that you did was really
Olympic level totally I but I did both I
did a lot of the my step brother stuff
like a lot of that and then I also would
do like really crazy stuff and like
honestly the crazy stuff it just like
pays more and it like gets you more
popular and like people that are like
super into porn are like into like the
insane stuff you know and like I was
like really looking to like you know
make a name for myself and I just kind
of knew that's how I was going to do it
but it's so crazy how like nothing in
real life will ever compare to like the
sex that happens in porn like there's no
way I could ever match that like I have
never in my life had sex with somebody
in real life and have them like match
the energy of like Mick blue or like
these really popular like porn
performers that like you know like just
have been professionally for like 20
years you know like you'll never find
that in real life and you guys want that
from you like when you hook up with a
guy for the first time are they like
expecting like a crazy no nothing they
expect literally nothing like I I maybe
I just like the type of guys that I I I
thought that that was going to happen
like I thought like oh well since I do
this stuff like every guy is going to
like want to do this and stuff but like
most guys are just like super super
normal and like I have to like talk them
into doing anal and you're
you're talk them into doing anal is my
dream I could never I'm always like
reject reject reject but you um you've
talked about how there are people who
are just born to do porn yeah totally
and like when you were younger you knew
that this is what you wanted to do was
it because of the performance aspect of
honestly think I just have like a sex
Obsession and something like I literally
like if I wasn't an actress I think I
would be like a sexologist or something
like I have a sex Obsession like I would
be like a sex therapist or something
like I love sex and like I just like
everything about it like I think it's
just like the greatest thing ever I just
think that like some people yeah are
just like born like being able to like
perform in that way and like so many
people like I remember when I first got
in were like this is so insane that
you're doing this but like there's like
it's just kind of like you know like
something that I always say is like
nobody chose to be born and we
definitely didn't choose to have to work
to live so a job should be all about
what kind of day that you can get
through and the kind of day that I could
get through was like having hardcore sex
you know like that's the kind of day I
could get through like I couldn't get
through the days that I had in the jobs
that I had before being a porn star and
then obviously like doing porn like it
really showed me how much I liked acting
and stuff and like now I like really
just want to be an actor from now on I
just felt like cuz for some reason I
just had this desire to like do it cuz
what I really liked about porn was that
you got to have a lot of sex but it took
out all the personal stuff from it like
you were having a lot of sex with
Attractive people that could like
really well but you didn't have to like
hit on them you know didn't have to Riz
them up or whatever like you didn't have
to like drama yeah and you didn't like
there just wasn't like all this like
complicated stuff like you didn't have
to fall in love with them even though I
did all the time fall in love with oh my
God would they get the vibe too yeah
this one guy I remember whenever we
would do scenes together we would like
we would come on set we'd lock eyes and
be like I miss you and then we would run
up to each other and like kiss each
other was like he was my husband or
something oh my God he wasn't my husband
and you never had also just sorry just
to clarify that's not how you would act
with a husband um I just want to make
sure I know you're young
um but that's so hot it was really hot I
think about it all the time yeah and you
guys never like dated off camera we
would like off camera we never
dated I don't really like I haven't been
in like a a monogamous relationship in
like a long time I like can't really
like handle being monogamous like I like
it literally terrifies me this idea of
like I'm just going to like one person
and it's like yeah you sound like my
ex-boyfriend have you always just been
in like open relationships then honestly
yeah like I but you've been a boyfriend
girl right you
I've had a lot of like boyfriends and
just like situationships and stuff like
that and like um I had like a girlfriend
and it was all all of it was all like
open like I've always had open
relationships and I think part of it was
because I was in porn and like they just
didn't feel like it was fair that like I
was people and that kind of just
like and then now that I'm out of porn
and I haven't been in porn or any sex
work in two years like every person I
see I still can't be like okay I'm just
having sex with you and like no what
else and it's weirdly gotten like worse
since I've gotten out of porn like now
like I just fully like can't imagine
being monogamous and like it uh kind of
drives people away but I'm fine with it
for now I think one day I'll change you
know one day I'll be ready also there's
so many people that are like poly and
but I don't want to be you want be I
don't want to label it I just want to
around you know like I just want to I
don't know like I don't want to I hate
the idea of like lay me like wear poly
like this is my primary partner like it
just
I know and then more fluid bonding that
really makes me uncomfortable that ter I
think the problem I really
had problem I had being single is that
like it's really hard for me to have
just casual sex one night stands are
just not something that I ever found um
like it didn't seem fun like if I didn't
have an initial connection with someone
if there isn't like some type of like
Mutual liking like I'm I'm out there has
many romances are fine like when you
have sex for three weeks four weeks like
those situations situationships but
outside of that like hookup culture is
weird to me I feel like I could not
survive a three-week thing because I'd
be like so we're just walking away after
3 weeks like I would be so chemically
bonded that I could I like that thought
also freaks me out I don't or they do
something so icky that it takes you out
of the chemical I've had that happen
where you're like oh we're nope this is
done I think for me it's cuz the first
time you have sex with someone is hard
it's rarely ever
that great like there is some type of
like learning curve so it's like I want
to hit that Peak before I exit but I've
had a guy where like he's like the sex
is like really good and crazy and he's
like spitting in my mouth and it's like
insane and then he's like it's three
weeks later and he wants to come to a
show and he's like trying to be funny
and I'm like why are you talking to Kyle
Canan do you know what mean I'm like I'm
so embarrassed you know and then I'm
like I got to go I'm still so turned off
by men that are too good at sex like
that's not like that's that's feminine
to me I don't know it's I don't like it
it's not your this what's too good at
sex like describe what too good at sex
is it's just like they're too confident
they're too they know their way like I
just I'm like they're not clunky there's
no awkward like you always say like if a
guy if you're hooking up with a guy and
you could tell he's using moves from the
last
girl it's just like let's start fresh
clean slate and you're right like the
first time with a new partner is never
that good but that freaks me out because
I'm like isn't the first time like the
only time guys like it with you like
totally oh my God yes cuz once guys have
had sex they're like okay time to kill
her time to kill her do and you can't
really when you're dating someone you
can't be like I'm waiting they want to
right away right I mean no I want
to right away like I just like what
the am I doing just like hanging
out with some man it's like like I have
male friends that like I don't but
like I'm not just going to like hang out
with just some guy and just like wait to
them I've never been able to never
no no way like if I'm attracted to you
like I want to you right away to
like figure out like if I like you cuz
like I get sex and love confused I kind
of like it and it's
working I think sex and love I'm trying
to think of where I stand on that
because initially okay so I want to
him as soon as I see him of course and
if there's an initial connection but I
think I do wait it out just because I
like the suffering of it all not even
for him but for me like I'm never like
an everyday sex kind of girl like even
though I could and it's probably
pleasurable I want to like build up and
like Edge out till like I'm like feeling
the suffering and I have like my own
version of blue balls yeah I like that
cool I can't believe that you want that
why it makes it hot I like it's like
with withheld yeah but I'm more like on
her thing of like let's just go what
when you when you know you know how fun
is it that when it's like a cooworker
like you can't tell anyone that's like
the hottest when you're like no one can
know that's the me well that's me and
Dave no one can know we have that we
have that down pat now I also read in an
interview that you said that like one
day you want to write a memoir and I
feel like all you know all of us girlies
like have that in Us in the back of our
head but I'm just curious like is there
any certain subject like I'm just
curious what would the Chloe Cherry
Memoir I think I want to like really
really really deeply get into like what
got me on Euphoria cuz there's this
misconception that because I made a
Euphoria porn parody that that's what
got me cast on Euphoria and that doesn't
make any sense to me cuz like why would
someone watch a porn parody and be like
oh they should be in the real thing cuz
like I also did like parodies of like so
many other things like that 70s Show and
they weren't like oh let's uh you know
like I don't know but like and I
actually made the porn parody myself I
produced it myself but I made it after I
had already gotten cast on the show
because I just like was like oh like I
might as well like do this because like
I don't know I just thought it would be
cool and like I didn't think it was be
going to become such a big thing but
like that's how everything is you know
you did it after you were cast on the
show after I was the and everyone says
the opposite exactly yeah and the way I
got cast on Euphoria was Sam levenson um
he like found my Instagram and like my
Instagram stories like I used to be like
before I was on Euphoria and like when I
had like less followers like I used to
be like very like like I would
constantly like make these like little
videos that where I would like just tell
jokes or like I would post memes and
like I would just have like a crazy
Instagram story and he was like really
intrigued by that so they just sent me
the audition and um I remember Sam
levenson on set told me that like I made
this video where I was like sitting in
the mall and I was like looking to the
side at people like this and he said
that he just loved my eyes and thought
they were perfect and like that's how I
got cast on the show that's what Sam
lenson tells me and like also I know it
wasn't from the Euphoria porn parody CU
I was cast before I had made that you
know and um so I don't know where the
people got that idea like who made
that up like I don't know it's just it's
scary having people like perceive you
like the narratives that are around and
you never can really can control them
totally it's so weird yeah exactly and
they love doing it people are just like
and I just like I'm like who is like out
here like coming up with these things
and just like why are they so correct to
people and like I don't know and I feel
like every podcast I go on I tell the
story that like I made the porn parody
after I had already been cast on the
show to celebrate being cast on the show
which is also
weird it's also a weird move I like it
hopefully you do a trash Tuesday porn
par after this she's out of the game
though um how would you say like your
life has changed since then and
obviously it sounds like you like since
then you quit porn but also like I don't
know do you go back to Lancaster where
you're from and like what's that like
being like on the biggest TV show like
of our of the current generation I mean
I do go back to Lancaster because like
my parents still live there and I like
to see them and um it's fine like it's
literally never anything crazy the only
thing that's bad is that like sometimes
I'll be out and like people I'll see
like people that like I went just school
with and they'll just be like staring at
me that's so funny does that feel a
little good though no not at all cuz I
they creep me out I don't know why
they're like that's the girl that used
to do the announcements you used to do
your school announcements right yeah
exactly that's so funny yeah how did
that how did you start doing the
announcements on your scho I just I knew
this teacher my favorite teacher in the
school was the guy who like ran the
morning announcements and I just asked
him one day I was like can I do the
morning announcements and he was like
yeah and uh but then eventually I like
stopped because I started like smoking
weed in the morning they were too slow I
just would like show up to school too
late by the time but yeah that was
pretty irresponsible to me but um yeah
they it was kind of weird going back to
Lancaster and like I don't know like and
then people will all the time like say
that they went to school with me that
they had class with me like I see that
all the time like you know I'll read
like my comments people will be like oh
I had class with her like I'll click on
the profile be like I've never seen you
in my life but that's kind of weird
about going to Lancaster that l people
like claim that they like knew me or
like they'll claim these like different
stories about me that like they had
hooked up with me or like whatever and
like they'll say all these things and um
but other than that like going back to
Lancaster is fun like I still have like
one friend there who was like my best
friend growing up and she's still there
and she's amazing and Lancaster for the
most part is pretty fun to go back to
there's great thrifting so you I had
heard on an interview that you did that
a lot of like your friends that you were
friends with in high school when you
started doing porn were like you ruined
your life and not a lot of them it was
just one girl this girl that like was
always like really really weird and like
I was kind of just friends with her
because like we were friends when we
were younger and then like you know like
you don't I'm the kind of person that
like I don't want to like abandon a
friend just because they're being crazy
and weirdo but like yeah she like said
this whole thing where she was like you
know you're never going to be able to
have a husband or children or anything
and like and it was just weird cuz like
I don't know I've had plenty of guys
like be like let's get married you know
I don't think it stopped me from
literally anything and um I just find it
so odd that she said that but I really
think that she said that because like
she when we were growing up always said
that she was going to be a model and
then she never became a model and I
think that she was like jealous that
like I actually went for something like
that instead of just like being too
scared I don't know and also now you are
a model I know you're all of the things
is there any part of you that's like
showed her you just don't even think
about about her anymore I mean I
honestly felt really bad for her for a
lot of like I still feel bad for her but
you know I think she was just kind of
like jealous and just kind of wanted to
hurt me but I then I like my best friend
growing up Lizzy like she literally like
was the one who gave me money to get a
cab to go to the airport to First go
shoot porn like she believed in me so
much and she I remember the night that I
before I left to go to Miami to like
shoot my first porn and she was like Hey
look at Kim Kardashian that's such a
good friend that is a good yeah she's
amazing yeah yeah so like my like actual
close friend like she like and then like
my other most of my friends I like still
talk to occasionally you know um they
were mostly completely accepting of it a
lot of them thought it was cool it was
just this one girl that I was friends
with that like was so horrible about it
and like I don't know why did when you
were little did you ever imagine being a
movie star yeah but I honestly didn't
think that I was like attractive or
talented enough for that like I thought
that like for some reason I was like
okay I'm good enough for pornography but
I didn't think I was good enough for
like modeling cuz like I guess growing
up like people weren't like talking
about how I was hot like it wasn't like
no one I don't know like it just wasn't
like a thing of me being attractive so
they were all Amish so they were making
Jam they were turning butter they
were busy they W looking at you there
but like I just never really thought I
was like just like hot or cool enough
you know I don't know so like do you
think you're hot and cool enough now uh
yeah I think I'm just about hot enough
just about I love that do you have any
impostor syndrome or anything my God yes
I like every time I'm on a plane I cry
because I just am
so nervous about my life and people
perceiving me and my future and stuff
for some reason on a plane it's because
I like I can't distract myself with like
my friends or the internet so I'm just
like there on the plane and I just I'm
like watching the Barbie movie and then
I just start like crying because I just
think about like I'm just so I have
horrible impostor syndrome like I
constantly think that like everything's
just going to like crumble down and
people are just going to you know what I
mean like I just I don't know like it's
just so hard for me relable wi that
really comes out for totally but you can
you can buy I I pay $50 a month
subscription and I am on the internet
the second I can be on a try Hawai airl
don't have but sometimes it doesn't even
work when it doesn't work it's rough if
it's over water it will not work unless
you know um but that's so relatable cuz
I feel like it's it's really only until
you've hit a certain goal that you
really start to feel the imposture
syndrome yeah like you go from like
delusion thinking oh I deserve this I
can get this I'm entitled to this and
then you get it and you're like I don't
deserve this everything's going to come
and then more things keep coming like oh
my God more and more and more totally
and then the more that people perceive
you like the more opinions are said
about you and the more that it like
with your brain cuz like you're
always like the subject of discussion to
people and like especially in like
certain like scenes and stuff like it's
just it's just weird like it just I
don't know it messes with your
perception and it's like's one thought
or the one like you know it's it's one
thing when you when you've done porn for
so long and people talk to you a certain
way or about you a certain way which
you're used to right they'll say
everything they want call you this call
you that but like what is the one thing
after you started on euphoria that made
you like really insecure like is my
acting good is is this like like what is
what were you feeling the impostor
syndrome over just like if I even have a
good enough personality to be anything
close to a celebrity you know like what
an interesting thought cuz it's like
aren't you all just like every
celebrities are they you don't have to
have anything good to be one yeah AR you
supposed to like show the director that
you could be nothing you're like I'm
supposed to show you I could have no
personality in this moment and take on
your personality that you bring yeah
that's an angle I guess but you know
what also is interesting I feel like
some actresses are like oh I hope it
doesn't all all my acting doesn't fall
apart and I have to do porn and you're
like youve reversed it so now you're you
kind of can only go you can not that
porns down but it's like totally do you
know what I mean you started at like a
high I've never heard of an actor be
like I would do porn if I either I think
that might now that I'm thinking about
it I also have not heard of that that
might be your plan that might be my plan
that might be where I'm headed there's
one thing that you've done a couple
videos on which I'm so envious of
because I think it's genius cuz
it's so regular and that's peeing in
public oh I love peeing in public I to
friends that just PE in public like you
know we have Jenna and she's like fil me
fil me and I'm like she did it slly is
the Renegade in this like she has that
my entire only fans was me peeing in
public that's so funny what do you mean
like just on the side of the road or
like or anywhere literally anywhere
different styles yeah different angles
anywhere and people loved it they loved
it and you don't do only fans anymore no
I mean if you were to go back I think
that's I think you could Po in public
now no no no no I that's disgusts me
more than anything but I think p is hot
and I um sterile right out you are you a
golden shower
girly um I honestly like every dude that
I have in like the past two years
has been like so vanilla they would
never do that like the guy that I like
dated for the longest like I would ask
him to do that he'd be like no what the
and then yeah just but like I feel
like I would but like it seems warm it
seems like of all the things it would be
like okay speaking of piss once and for
all I know you've already said this in
another interview but like I need you to
demystify squirting oh and tell the
world what it is well every time that I
demystify squirting and then I like
there's always like a Reddit thread that
comes up where they're like Chloe
Cherry's just jealous that she doesn't
squirt and it's like no like I did porn
like I worked with people that were like
very famous for squirting in the
industry and I would watch them like
drink a bunch of water Pedialite was
what they really liked and like that's
how they would get those like big
Squirts and like isn't it like doesn't
it just feel like logical that like you
would have to drink a lot of water for
that that like your body isn't just that
it's not I don't I but that's how it
works squirt in porn it is but like your
body could like squirt but it's not
going to be like the way in porn it's
like where it's yeah like giant like
totally that's not the way that like
real like like the sprinkler that like
your can be like so wet and juicy
that it like squirts a little bit but
like it's not going to be like big
squired where it's like you're in a huge
puddle and yes and I don't it's not like
consistent It's just sometimes but I
also cannot come if I have to pee so
it's like so I don't know where the
squirting comes in totally I I just
guess the reason I always say that about
squirting is because that's what
everybody did in the industry was they
would have to like drink a bunch of
water like no one just like came to set
and was like just sprain it's Prett
rough it's pretty rough it's hard it's a
hard life you got to bring quarters for
people to do their laundry it's like
what is the history like when did it
first like appear in porn I think it's I
don't know when it first appeared in
porn um I'm pretty sure it was like the
2010s but don't like take my word for it
but like what the reason why men like it
is because like men that watch porn tend
to like not really like men that watch
like a lot of porn and like that's where
like they basic like they don't really
like have sex in real life they just
kind of watch porn like they don't
really comprehend the idea of like
coming without something spraying out
yeah they can't understand so like they
like don't comprehend the idea that like
a woman could just like come and like
nothing sprays out of her cuz like when
they come something sprays out of them
so like they don't understand that like
a woman could come and like nothing
sprays out it's probably attached to
their ego too yeah totally totally to be
like well if this is what I've seen
women can do like let me get you there
and it's like I my body doesn't do that
I mean I can just pee all over you if
that's what you want then having a
pregnancy aversion to Annie squirt like
it's triggering my acid reflux the
thought of it triggers Todds
too um so are we still undecided on
whether or not like I don't know like I
don't feel it's p I'll say when it
happens it doesn't feel like the same as
P really so you're like our evidence
here like it just doesn't it doesn't
look this I don't know I've I've never
tasted pee or my squirt but I I'll
investigate I just never know when it's
gonna happen I porn they like drink a
bunch of water to do it yeah so like
when you're watching porn I'll try I'll
investigate porn stuff is like out like
otherworldly like they're spraying the
whole room and it's like every five
seconds any time they tap it it's
exactly exactly that's what I'm talking
about like that's not that's like you
have to like drink a lot of water and
like pee cuz like I used to do squirting
scenes and like I would just drink a ton
of water and like yeah it's um but like
I have seen like riy re squirts for real
but it's literally
like you know like I know the first time
I squirted I was in a hotel room that
had a hot tub in it so maybe my
like keegel it in maybe maybe I absorbed
it in like really humid in the room and
you were moist and then you have um I've
heard you talk about um anal orgasms
yeah and how you describe it actually
makes sense to me no one has ever
described it before in this way where
you're basically just hitting the G-Spot
but from a different angle right yeah
yeah yeah it's like from the other like
your G-spot is like deep in your
and then like it you if you can get in
your ass like you can hit the G-Spot
from the other way so it's like a deeper
prostate basically yeah yeah kind of
like that and I've heard that like some
people like cuz your G-spot can be
positioned in like different places
depending on like the person and I've
heard that like for some people it like
hits more than others and like I don't
know it's different for everybody you
know does anyone have theirs in their
throat they just come that where yours
are when they're blowing guys I have a
question going back to the pee so you
don't like poop cuz one of my friends I
hate poop I'm scaring my boyfriend my
friend boyfriend wanted a pictures they
bring it out they have it on a tray
they're like oh you're grossed St by
this I'm very an I'm a very anti- poop
girl too I hate I don't admit to do it
in front of my partner no matter like
who they are like even if it's my mom
I'm just like don't poop in my house
like no one's no if I'm in a hotel room
with a boy I go down to the lobby to use
the bathroom I do not go in my parents
won't let me poop in our house but it's
cuz there's a sewage issue and my Dad
recently the last two trips home has
asked me if I could save my poop for
when I go to a gas station I'm like Dad
I'm pregnant like this is not
sustainable yeah no I'm door open eye
contact I like watchingg my man poop we
have the days it's nice and clean I mean
I don't really mind um someone else
doing it in front of me like just me
personally like I I'm so shy about it
every guy I've dated in the past like 10
years has had to take a on our
first date in my apartment it's like
crazy one time I had a guy over to
and he comes in he's like hey and he
goes I'm going to I'm going to go to the
bathroom really quick and then uh he is
in there for a long time and then like
he opens the door and it like smells I'm
like took a and I literally just
like you have to go
home home yeah I sent him home hear
about this on first dates and I'm like
you got to just call the date like you
can't do that why who are these people
it's we didn't Todd did that and we did
not hook up do an enema before every
date we did like what are they that
confident normalized enemas men normaliz
enemas they probably think it's gay
they're like it's gay to do an enma I
love anma I always used to feel bad
about like
I used to feel bad for the girls that
would have to poop at the club like you
ever go to a club and you go to the
restroom and someone is like struggling
and you're like all the places
like it couldn't happen before they're
sloppy that's a sloppy move that means
they didn't like up before they
went out yeah or they did a lot of
cocaine oh really that makes a lot of
sense stimulant any stimulant will make
you poop like coffee but wonder I can't
relate but why is it so bad to do it at
the club like you look so pretty you're
so doled up you're like can you imagine
Esther's legs like dangling under the
thing as she poop five more minutes
you're wearing like like cute CL my my
purse turned into a Squatty Potty when I
flip it
over it makes have a Squatty Potty in
your
purse it makes me sad to think of myself
getting so glammed up putting in all
that effort choosing their right shoes
and then realizing like oh I have
to take a in like this public
bathroom not disagree more it's like
that is such a bonus to your night like
now I'm going to feel better like I'm
going to have I'm going to be lighter
girls are on the couch these are the PE
girls PE versus poop that's this episode
guys I definitely please don't call it
that I promise not put poop in the title
for you no I do want to clarify I am
also afraid of poop like that's
obviously such a scary thing like all
right I'm poop I'm poop you guys are
pee like when you have
you know when you do it in the back in
the back space Oh my I listen I'm scared
of residue okay when I I did when I did
anal it was like a to-do I did it with
one guy one I was I'm not an anal girl
maybe in the future but as of now not it
was such a to-do with this guy that I
was calling all my gay friends I was
calling point stars they were so over me
they were like this is so embarrassing
to ask it's like if someone asked us
like how to start doing comedy like
where do you do your first open mic I'm
like how do you do anal this girl was
like we're done I ate soup for breakfast
I did an enema the guy that I was living
with needed to come up I had to buzz him
in so I took the enema and then he like
he did the buzzer and I had to like cut
my ass and like run to the door oh and
then come back it was wild it was it was
wild and I did not on his ass I
feel like if you're doing anal prep it's
like the KN needs to go on your time
like he can wait he needs to wait at the
door it wasn't we knew it was h no
that's the different guy that was like
the my roommate and then I was going to
like the hotel it was he got a hotel it
was like an anal hotel we don't we went
an anal can you name anal hotels is it
higher an anal Hotel I don't remember
what it was but it was on it was near
the bus I was going to see my nieces and
I would take the bus to Boston from New
York so he got a hotel near the bus it
was like very sweet it was a gentleman
and so then I'm on the phone with my
friend and on the bus like and I'm
trying to be quiet but I'm so loud and
I'm like and then he me in the ass
and I like did this enema and I'm like
telling the whole anal story I get to my
sister-in-law I would meet my
sister-in-law at her work she's like
works at this bank and fraud like she's
like a a big deal and it's a very proper
place and I get there and she goes um
one of my uh employees just asked if you
were on the bolt bus because her sister
was sitting in front of you and heard
everything you said Annie oh my gosh you
had that full conversation I feel like
it's more embarrassing for her to have
like Eaves Dro unless you were really
just announcing ing it to the whole I
don't know I don't know my volume I you
I will say if you got to e drop on that
kind of conversation on bus juicy you
lucky in all the way the whole thing was
very good I want to get back to anal
hotels do can we can we agree Hilton
Hyatt anal hotels yes um any Boutique
familyowned bed and breakfast not anal
hotels I don't know it's nice to have a
nice home-cooked meal afterwards no but
you want a hotel where you can like call
down on the front desk in like 24 hours
yeah you can leave a 100 you can leave
them like look I made a mess but it's
like you're not usually making a mess no
no no no I've never had like aanal
experience you want extra towels when
you need them you want room service you
know you might you might be sore
whatever do you guys ever take a modium
um only if it's intractable diarrhea and
I'm on my sixth day of like death oh wow
but that's the lube I take a modium
every time I do anal just so you make
sure it's not cuz it stops and then I
like Ena a lot and right it works and
then are you kind of like are you like
stuck stuffed up afterwards does push it
up afterwards cuz my sister-in-law had
to make me um she had to make me uh
chilly and then my niece came up to me
she's like here Auntie my mom told me to
give you a prune so cute a I got fudge
packed G triggering conversation for the
pregnant
lady don't picture it no i' I I've been
doing have you done a supposit
it's like vaginal not anal oh okay way
to one up me um but like you stick
something up your butt and then it like
triggers and then that's you start
pulsing it kind of yeah I don't know why
but it just like it's all
greasy it is always very greasy they
usually add a lot of O It's a tablet of
Grease yeah cuz they have suppositories
for hemorrhoids they the one that I take
is canesa which um we did on the live
show I put a suppository up my but you
did I don't remember that it up I was
blackout drunk from my belly
button yeah no I I'm very happy with my
relationship with suppositories right
now I had a great morning what kind of
suppositories do you take it's oh it's
the brand Fleet rules you know
it have at home Fleet enemas yeah
not with you I see you I see you way to
Branch out Fleet I see good job I'm like
they've changed my life I have a fleet
fetish
I do too I really do do you do foot
stuff yeah yeah yep I uh I suck toes
okay and I like my toes sucks and uh I
love giving foot jobs okay I've never
given my feet life like I'm not talking
about Point anymore this is like my own
personal okay is it like when okay cuz
I've never done we had a foot guy on
here a couple episodes ago my feed I'm
saving my feet for marriage but okay but
do you like is it like when you go to
give a blow drob and you kind of like
Kiss down the do you kind of of like run
your toes down their waist and like no
I'm pretty is their foreplay is their
foot foreplay I'm I think maybe because
I did so much porn I'm kind of just
straight to the chase I'm like do you
want a foot job sit down do you slowly
seductively take your socks off wait do
you hand them a card that says Circle
yes or no then you come back do you foot
job to completion I it's pretty hard you
have to be like really into feet to do
that so
I think I did like in porn but I don't
think I have like in my personal life
done a foot job to completion usually
it's just like a fun little thing that
you can can I pitch you a title for your
Memoir yeah Chloe pops your cherry yeah
I was I have an idea for it I'm not
going to share it but I'm thinking of it
in my head right now and it's a good
idea okay I feel rejected but it's
okay look you make pitches in life I
know I know I know keeps you strong
keeps you strong you can't ever be
rejected but CH you're a collage artist
right or you're just a performance
artist you're an everything artist yeah
I'll do anything honestly to be creative
cuz like when I get bored or like sad I
just want to like be creative and I did
a different interview this morning and
they were talking about my rapping on um
SoundCloud and I was like I don't even
think I'm good I just I don't know it's
just something to do you know and that's
why I on Soundcloud and not Spotify and
um that I do make the collages which I
think are better than the rapping it's
like objectively better um but still
like I haven't made one in a while cuz I
also like don't really I also have
imposter syndrome of that where I'm like
there's no way I could be an artist an
artist you know like yeah I heard you
saying you're were like I wish I could
just sell my collages as a job I wish
that I I could like I didn't have to
like all I didn't have to like
constantly be like getting like doing
auditions and like you know getting
rejected or like you know getting the
role or like you know like I wish that
like my collage is sold for like
millions of dollars like that's what I I
wish was going on you know I feel the
same way cuz I draw and it's like
sometimes like with comedy it's like
it's just never ending like Esther knows
it's like we make a like we make our set
and then there has to be a new set and
then it's like it's always like growing
and evolving so there's never really
like an end to anything and um sometimes
like I was doing uh this Festival in
Vegas and I was on Fremont EV and I was
like watching like the tin guy and I was
like who by the way inspired my outfit
but I'm like I picked something too hard
I was like I could just be there's like
a guy like weaving things together and
selling them I was like why am I not
just weaving something I would love to
draw and sell that no that like sounds
so much more meditative than what we do
but don't you think it would turn into
the same thing I think it would be the
same then it would be like it's too hard
to create art but I I feel really
similarly to you where it's like it
doesn't need to be good like I just do
it I need to when I'm bored or sad or
alone like I need to do something
creative to express myself and I found
that I've really I think a lot of us
judge ourselves where it's like well
it's not good or no one's going to see
this so why am I writing it and I just
am really working on getting those
voices out of my head because it is sort
of just to stay afloat to just get
things out is really good and also like
my fiance and I get into this like
argument a lot so like when if we ever
do like a craft not to flex um but like
so we were making St sings for the
holidays and he you are really Nest
you're nesting I know I don't know how
this happened but he was like they fish
nuts we find out he was it's for our
anal location he was like um your color
pal like he was just like nitpicking my
color palette he's like you're G to just
I go really fast when I do it and sloppy
and he's like it's supposed to be neat
and cute and I'm like no it's supposed
to we live different lives baby well
that's like like that's the entire book
of like Rick Rubin right like where he's
basically like like the reason he's so
good at his job and has been like has
produced like you know iconic albums is
because he doesn't care about what
people like he only trusts what he likes
so it's like for him it's like like real
like artists it's like you you've just
got to like what you put out like
without even thinking about you're real
artist Dave's a fake one yeah you're
realtist comment below
da Dave is also making what he likes
probably more better than I am so yeah
more better let's be more better this
year I want to let you know she was sick
a while ago and isn't still sick yeah I
was sick like weeks ago it was just the
common cold I got tested for everything
it was just a common cold I told her
ahead of time that you've been cursed
with Co so you I've never had Co in my
life what yep what is your blood type
like I don't know sparkly
D the oh my God oh my God don't put
that banana there you're making us funny
look B oh my God too hot Chloe Cherry
too hot I can't believe you didn't know
you were hot honestly I still don't know
no one will she our
K know no that I'm hot took a while it's
really hot super hot thank you thank you
I I we had dinner at Pache Yi and Sawyer
and I remember sitting down so's like
come on in I'm having a meeting um with
someone but just come in
and as soon as I saw it was you I was
like oh my God I was like I can't even
look her way right now I swear to God do
you remember that yeah totally did you
go in the bathroom and I was nervous to
meet you I was like she's too cool for
me yeah but we didn't say a single word
to each other I think that's what
happens where I'm like oh God like the
same reason like how I don't know how to
flirt with boys I actually like but I
know how to effectively flirt my God I
was just talking about that with my
friend yeah that like ugly guys like you
can just like throw game at them but
then guys actually like you just
completely ignore and just like oh I've
never like yeah I'm like you can't if a
guy thinks they can have me I'm like I
don't know how to if I think a guy's hot
I mute him on Instagram and never talk
to me 100% 100 literally always say the
first night I met my met Dave when I saw
him my first thought was that guy's hot
I need to stay away from him I need to
hide yeah I think something short
circuits in our brains where it's like
it's almost like I cannot stand the
thought of possibly Desiring this person
and handle the rejection of it all so
it's like how about I just like delete
him from my head myself up with an ugly
guy you're like it's like I can write
this off of my taxes this is you're
gonna be so grateful and then you like
date them and they're so me do you and
you're like oh wait my bad wait that is
that is so true by the way they're
always oh I thought this was going
to be really easy you no cuz
you're like oh wait I'm so much cuter
than you you're going to be really nice
to me uh no not not all the time yeah me
the have you ever had like a like a
boyfriend or like some guy that you're
like just seeing or whatever and like
you like can very much objectively tell
like he's like less attractive than you
but he's like so sure that he's
like hot hot hot hot hot that would piss
me off to no end yes that's like yeah
that's I feel like every guy that I date
they're just like I mean I'm I'm really
attractive so like I always get this
female attention I'm like what are you
okay sure and then you and then to like
tell him the truth you'd have to be like
well I was actually doing kind of like a
low self-esteem thing where I was like
trying to get you to like put me on
pedestal and then you have to like admit
too much wait is that a really unfair
question to ask um your partner like who
do you think the hot one is in the
relationship I I'm going to ask that in
my next relationship I that every time
I've done that many times and the answer
is if it's not you fight right the one
answer is that you you are like of
course being with a guy who identifies
as hotter than you like no no sir lose
all your power you don't want to be my
ex I know you're like delusion okay but
I chose you so here we go we have to be
the prize I think that's like our job I
love being toally yeah I agree but it's
hard with like men in La like they think
they're like really cool and hot and
like they're like look at my car like
okay you have rims on a Honda good job I
think it came from that I think it came
from the place like that I think you
bought
them Dave like I I one thing I love
about him is that he really does not
spend money on himself like he has no
self-confidence
so he just like that's her favorite
thing he has like shitty car just like
but I think you guys are going to like
Drop cash on your kids that's what my
mom keeps saying I don't think so we
already we're getting our all of our
Nursery from Ikea we're like this
it doesn't last long totally cuz the
kids grow so quickly why like why would
we invest in like a nice Nursery or
whatever but so last night I was
thinking I was finally like I guess it
would be kind of nice to be with a man
who like had a nice had nice stuff that
I could like share we could share our
lives but but yeah this is what I chose
I chose the Honda Civic for life well
you don't want Honda Civic but I have
like a a brand new one and I'm really
into it I love Honda Civic I have a
brand new Toyota Corolla and really nice
they're amazing yeah they're so fast
they're so good yeah Teslas are faster
but I'm so sorry guys I had Honda 2 and
it was fun and fast and then I got the
Tesla and I'll never go back yeah I just
feel like such a douchebag if I
got a Tesla like oh that's the best part
that's the best part you cut people off
and you're not there for their it's like
you manage those emotions I'm gone baby
I'm no longer around you can find me yes
I'm doing my makeup I feel I my Toyota
Corolla identifies as a Tesla I would
love to see you clim me into a Tesla
you'd be so cute in a Tesla we should
get you the Tesla um the X where the
doors go up that's a good mom car the
Toyota Cora really is legit though I'm
obsessed with that Caron cuz my mom has
one
Toyotas roll I had Toyotas my whole life
they absolutely r no I get in it
I'm like this is or Hondas sorry I like
Hondas I've had Hondas like my whole
life I always had cameras like that and
then I had a weird thing happen where I
had to switch to Hondas and I was like
it was good but it was like I did miss
my what do you mean a weird thing it was
like a a documentary that I did I was in
The Comedy Store documentary and they
wanted to do a a storyline where this
old comic from The Comedy Store who was
working as a car salesman now at Honda
was gonna like The Comedy Store was
gonna like hook me up with this car so I
went to Alan burki at Ocean Honda and
they sold me a car that was so much more
expensive than the Toyota I had and put
me out so bad and the g it was like a
gas guzzler and it was to the point
where it was like it was a problem and
there was no storyline about it and I
just had a car I was like I just signed
at lease there was no help I forgive and
I forget and guys watch The Comedy Store
documentary on Showtime episode four and
five are the cutest there will be
nothing about the Honda Civic in the
show you will not know anything but you
may see some tension what was the cool
boy car in high school like for me it
was if you had um it was a hatchback
that was the sh J J everyone had a Jetta
everyone J the had Jettas every I mean I
would have never it might have been
Pennsylvania yeah in Pennsylvania every
has a Jetta for us it was
the um Honda but the hatchback okay no
we would have thought that was I would
have been like really Acuras were cool
um Alis was King and then a lot of my
friends had like the older old Mustangs
those were cool like musle cars my
friend Alex who was a drug dealer who
was like making like I think he's I
think maybe Rip but uh we're not sure
most of the kids from my high school are
no longer with us but um he she's not
really old she just went to like a a
school for bad kids yeah
they I'm 97 years old I'm the class of
97 not because of the year but because
of my age but um
so yeah he drove a Lexus that was like
and he made like $50,000 selling Coke
like he was like the cool guy but guys
it didn't turn out well for him so I'm
going to tell you now you shouldn't be
making 50 Grand a month in high school
you might not make it holy 50 Grand
a month in high school it was crazy it
was crazy it was crazy everyone was dead
also his mom his mom um ohab was cool
yeah was kind of though but you're from
Vermont Vermont's different what do you
mean like volw rabbit Volkswagen Rabbit
would be cool there my dad had did this
crazy thing that I will never forget the
first time we uh came to America from
the Philippines I was a teenager and he
was really proud about this car that he
had purchased for the family which was
like a French car called A Renault and
I'm telling you it was like the only
Rena in Los Angeles and it broke down
like the second day we were here there
wasn't a
Renault it wasn't practical but it was
no it wasn't but like my dad was really
into sobs too cuz he was like they make
planes or something like that I was like
okay like very European yeah my dad was
into sobbing there was a lot of
cries I've been trying to get that edge
that one in for a while would she
brought up sobs I'm sorry that's what I
thought at first too was just sobs like
oh like yeah of course my boy okay my
boyfriend that I dated um freshman year
of high school who basically R my life
he took my Virginia on a water bed he he
was in prison for years not for
me but um he had he had a Dodge Neon it
was like red and he had rims on it and
he would he would wear like his hat like
kind of like on top of his head and he
would lean back his seat so you could
only see like the little button on the
top of his head and he would be like
driving like this Brad and he would come
in we're like Brad's so cool he's so
awesome and then he told the whole
school I like a dead fish which I
think is up when I was literally
swimming I was on a water bed it's like
that is such a mean thing toin actually
ruined my life it made me so insecure to
people but also like okay can I
just say though to defend to not to not
to defend Brad or men who talk like
about like women but like the stuff that
I've said about men to like my girl
friends like he obviously told everyone
that like out school had 17 kids
graduating class so he just had to say
it whisper it once in the whole yeah but
that's like up right but like
like I think you've actually mentioned
this on a show where it's like we say
worst things
moreit and more detail to each other
about our sex stuff than men ever do I
wonder though is it a reaction to having
been talked on for me is it like
okay this did this and I'm
telling every I'm going to say tell
every centimeter also dead fish was such
an insult for us when we were younger
right I'm trying my best I'm 14 years
old I can barely ride a bike I learned
how to ride a bike three years ago Dude
like I remember a guy telling me one
time like no he didn't tell me he told a
bunch of our friends he was like yeah
you know she was like fun to but
she didn't have enough ass and I was
like you and this guy was so
ugly like probably of all the guys I've
ever the ugliest guy I've ever
in my life and he had the
nerve I thought I was like this was a
charity case I thought I was like being
Mother Teresa and being like you know
what bleep his name out I was like you
know what I'm G to give looks like he
hasn't been laid in a while I was like
I'm gonna his ugly ass talk to
you and bleep that out again but and
then we had sex and he told a bunch of
my guy friends like yeah she just didn't
have enough of ass for me and I'm like
what the bro you didn't have enough
dick for me there's a lot of things you
were missing but I was you have enough
chin so interesting that like people in
high school were saying that like when
you them cuz everyone that I had
sex with in high school like never said
anything I don't know I I mean at least
it never got back to me and maybe that's
why I became a porn star cuz I was so
confident in my sex abilities I'm
thinking that you're say that girls say
worse about I think guys are worse no
cuz guys are not in as detailed like
when we say stuff they are detailed I've
I've heard even men have talked to me
about guys or girls that they'
and it's like they're it's like
up I'm like why are you saying this yeah
like my what I've heard my guy friend
say and I'm always like I don't say
stuff like this not even to you guys
like I I don't feel the need like even
like the person I was with who had a MP
Myro master plan
I like have positive I found positive
reviews I think it's not necessarily I'm
not talking about talking I'm
talking about the details we exchang
with each other about the sex that we're
having oh I feel like I like will like
talk but to my friends I'm not
going to like go to his friend they'd be
like you want to know something about
your friend you know like yeah that
would actually be amazing zero out of 10
go tell him I think I've done that I
think a guy who gave me BV I was like he
needs to wash his dick more I think I
like told everyone in Santa Fe I mean
that's like but that's just Public
Health announcement I'm like tell your
friend to wash his dick like what the
hell dude yeah they gave you something
that's fair that's smelling the whole
time his like famunda cheese it
was like he wasn't like he didn't wash
his uncircumcised dick enough
and then and he was so mad at me cuz I
really he tried to me for so long
and I finally and it was good sex but
then it was nasty I'm like ew you left
me with a fish
filla I smell so nasty it was so gross
guys talk about everything it's like and
this is what I just tell them like like
they'll complain about like different
kinds of smells or the you know girl
they hooked up with wasn't clean enough
or I just did that what it's just funny
cuz I just did that about him oh yeah
but I don't I don't know I'm just I
always tell my I'm like you guys are gay
like you just don't like vaginas I think
a lot of guys are there was this guy in
porn that I loved working with who would
tell me that like he didn't like he
couldn't get as turned on when a girl
was like super clean she like douched a
lot and like wore a bunch of perfume
that like his dick wouldn't get as hard
cuz she didn't like smell like a natural
woman I like that I like when guys are
like that that's fun when they want you
a little that's definitely the
preference of the
showell a natural person I I almost feel
like that was um a problem the the guy
that I'm seeing now has just no body
odor and I'm like a kid like scratch and
sniffing you know scratch and sniff
stickers I do that like I keep searching
for as scent because I'm like I need to
know that you stink a little or you have
like some type of like you know odor
about you but he just doesn't and Bobby
didn't either no body odor nothing do
you think it's be do you think he's like
cleaning himself a lot before he no it's
no it's not it's like a it's genetic he
has a ruggedy job too so he would be
have a no he works in the office how can
office ruggedy job okay okay an like I
was like Annie has like a fantasy that
she masturbates to your no no no I was
right but he does the office job of the
ruggedy yeah um no but um Bobby had the
same thing where it was like he just
never had body odor cuz he you know some
Koreans some Asians don't I found it to
be really unfair but yeah I know it
sucks when there's a smell in the room
and it's not mixed you're like oh it's
just me oh I wonder what I smell
like I feel like I just can't tell like
I always like trying to like smell
myself and like ask people if like I
smell whatever they're like no but like
obviously they're just being nice and
you have a keen sense of smell for like
other things around you yeah yeah but I
feel like I have like a pretty like my
nose isn't really that sensitive like I
can deal with like bad smells and stuff
yeah you can that's right because that
is interesting CU like that's a good
thing sensory adaptation really is a
thing right cuz there are people who do
not smell their own Bo and it is very
very strong that's I constantly worry
that that's me oh no I worry about that
too yeah someone would tell you someone
would tell you I think if you're a
pretty girl someone will tell you okay I
think if you're like a nasty big dude
people are like you're already a nasty
big dude a except I do tell people
like there's some people that that work
in my area who are really and I'm like
you you have you can't smell like this
this is crazy or I make jokes or
whatever but I had a friend when I had a
TV show four episodes you guys might
have missed it it was on e um I had a
hired a writer on it and he had such bad
Bo that I had to pull him aside and I
was like I just want to help you for
your next writing job like you have to
like when you take your shirt off at
night and you wash it you have to scrub
the armpits then wash it then you can't
just take a piece of clothing off the
ground and put it back on how did he
take it he acted like kind of insulted
at first and I was like I need you to
really know that I'm I'm telling you
this to help you yeah that's really
interesting cuz I don't know how I feel
about that like it sounds like there's
almost you can't win in that
conversation okay so this is how I felt
we were at the ebuilding and there was a
moment where he was on the elev with
Maria manuno and I went I did something
weird it's like the butterfly effect
when they go back in time and like I
felt like I like shifted history by
having the two of them on the same
elevator like I was like this was these
people were never supposed to meet and
now nothing will be the same yeah yeah
like something there's an earthquake
somewh so you felt like this
responsibility I just also he was going
into like a more serious writer room
afterwards and I did I just wanted to
and I and I knew his boss there was
going to be like actually very mean
about it so I was like I really was
trying to do him a
do you think he was he still smells like
yeah I feel like people that smell
bad no matter what you tell them to do
they're still going to smell bad cuz
like it's just inherently them and as
long as I'm out next to them on an
airplane which has happened to me before
I'm usually cool but I I there is this
theory that sometimes like I I often
think I I often think about which is
like do people smell or are biologies
just don't match because I have found
that couple say for instance I had a my
my high school one of my high school
best friends and her husband both had
really bad breath but they had the same
flavor of bad breath but they really
liked each other and so I was like oh
like this sort of like makes sense that
maybe it they don't like smell it on
each other and maybe my breath to them
just is really unattractive so it's like
I think it there is like an element of
like like just biologically matched or
not right for some smells yeah for some
yeah obviously not like you know you
didn't wipe
well I hate the way said nightm what a
nightmare I hate the way you said that
nightm wait you're a poop girl I thought
you'd love that one oh I come in with my
skid marks I say get ready baby let's go
no I just I will for the sake of having
an argumentative a good balanced panel I
will be the poop girl but if I if I were
to the hemoroid girl last time you keep
taking the I'll take it guys I'll take
it I've got my man I'm good I'm good you
got to steady it's okay to be the poop
and hemorrhoid girl there's there has to
be representation for everyone and I'm
here for you are we doing the a last
thing we Googled thing yeah should I get
my phone yes
okay the last thing I Googled was the
baby list showroom which is so sad the
last thing I Googled was food near me
and then I Googled myself and then I
Googled Maru coffee Los fiz and then I
Googled aalda vintage I Googled BMI
calculator you're such an LA Queen that
is as La as La gets Maru BMI calculator
and what was the Googling yourself Googl
yourself Googling yourself is good wow
that is the ultimate la like check-in I
think yeah totally and that's like every
day for me honestly mine is a peace and
love based Community sound bath that's
kind of a very Annie that's kind of La
let's see for sure okay my last three
are um this year's influenza virus this
year's flu shots efficacy which is at
52% yeah I got it and then got the flu
so okay yes at 52% and and then the next
thing was um a bakery that has the snow
puffies after that I Googled oh these um
BGA vaneta sunglasses oo I was looking
at
houses a five bedroom or no five baths
five bedroom for six million oh Lord is
that your the range you're looking at
Annie I'm just looking you know have a
little fun 6 million for a five bedroom
they just I just there was a QR code on
this one house and then these are all of
theirs and I went oh okay whose BMI are
you calculating M wait I want to talk to
you about food and what your what Your I
do I I I uh I have some kind of
obsession you could say diet and
exercise baby tell us everything okay so
um I mean I've thought about this a lot
I used to always say like you know like
I used to say that I just like eat
whatever I want and like because I
thought that that was like it was really
unethical to be like oh I like try to I
thought it was unethical to like show
that to like younger people and stuff or
like more vulnerable people that like
you you know do certain things to look a
certain way um but like now I feel like
it's actually more ethical to just be
honest about it and like I do like Diet
like a lot and like I exercise a lot but
I mostly exercise through walking
cuz it's like the
only dude walking is like the only thing
that like keeps my weight down and like
keeps me toned and stuff like everything
else I do that just like doesn't work
well enough for me like running also
works but like I prefer walking and um
yeah and I have like crazy eating habits
like most days I don't eat anything
until 5:00 p.m. and then I'll stop
eating at 10 p.m. okay and it's like a 5
hour fasting window and like um I
honestly I just like having the control
and stuff and like I also have like an
obsession with like my body and what I
look like and like how people perceive
me that like I just you know I refuse to
like really let myself like you know I
try to eat like one meal a day usually
and like I just refuse to let myself
like get carried away and start like
snacking all the time and like cuz
anytime I have like I literally just
feel so guilty about it like so bad
about it that like it feels cleaner me
to just drink like my black coffee in
the morning and then nothing until 5:00
p.m. and I don't know it just feels good
and I like having the control and like
it just feels I don't know I just enjoy
the control that I have over it and like
controlling it and like and like I like
being like skinny for some reason it
just like fulfills me even though like I
like have body dysmorphia and like I
don't feel like I'm skinny but like I
like being like you know having like a
low BMI or whatever like it just makes
me feel better about myself you know I
think that's super relatable I think in
most I spent most of my 20s just being
like hyper fixated on every single
calorie like I knew the nutritional um
like the nutritional label of like
ketchup like I knew how much sugar like
how many net carbs cuz I was like
hardcore into Atkins before they like
repackaged it as like keto or whatever
and even today right like I was at the
doctor's before this and I don't owe a
weighing scale because I do know I have
that disordered kind of like um um
mentality like around food and exercise
and I was like don't weigh yourself I
was like you can't escape that they have
to weigh you at the doctors and I almost
had a meltdown as soon as I I
saw my weight I not only cried I had to
call my sister she had to console me and
I was like do I really look that big
like how like like I just like full on
just me like hating myself and I hate
that that thing like will now dictate
like the rest of the week cuz I was
actually feeling sort of nice when I
woke up and but I totally know what you
mean and I think that you know a lot of
things in my childhood led to the fact
that maybe like I had no sense of
control but this is the one thing I
could control which is like diet and
exercise so I throw it all in there and
I'm a lot better now like cuz I'm you
know almost 40 but in my 20s like my God
like I would run until I would lose all
my toenails like OV exercise and then
like restrict restrict restrict and you
know like I I get it but I'm thank you
for not pretending that oh I'm just you
know I
I eat like pizza but it's like one or
two slice and that's all I eat in the
day you know and you probably clock it
it's something that you thought about
very you know I I totally get that like
I think I'm sort of just like you know
um there are people on one side of the
fence who are like you know we shouldn't
be talking you shouldn't be openly
expressing like things that you're
disordered about or even saying that out
loud but it's like no I'd rather have
people tell me so I don't feel
so alone in my
obession I want to throw my hat in the
ring and say that being pregnant is
really up for your body image
because it's there's so much pressure to
not be insecure or not speak out about
it because it's like this is when you're
growing a baby like it's you're supposed
to this is healthy but it doesn't that
all that can be true but it doesn't also
mean that I'm not like feeling away yeah
looking at certain things and obviously
I'm you know all of the things it's
beautiful and I'm happy to be putting on
weight and have just want a healthy baby
but like it's still hard it's still like
I still look at other women's bodies who
are skinny and I'm like I want to be
that right now yeah are you kidding me
aser that that is so real
because one of my biggest Hang-Ups about
when I think about getting pregnant is
my vanity yes 100% for you I hate that
it is that way and I wish I didn't have
to like say it out loud because people
were like well you know your body is
meant for this it can handle this and be
proud of your tiger stripes and it's
like you know what I have a hard enough
time with my body not being pregnant
like I I know I'm going to be really
hard on myself and yeah I am vain in
that way yeah and your nipples are going
to get so yeah and it's big and again
like yeah like I love how you're like
the expert on all the damage the body
damage
but you've never been pregnant CL I've
clapped it I've been thinking about it
I'm the oldest I'll just take that as
the oldest I'm the oldest of the crew I
had a thing happen to me over okay so
over Thanksgiving my one of the
brother-in-laws that was hanging out
with us at this we were at the Jersey
Shore he was doing cold plunges in the
morning so he had like my mom and I went
my mom's in her 70s to go do a cold
plunge so we were just going in naked
and he's like a photographer's like do
you want me to film it and I was like
whatever healthy thing will happen from
me going to this cold plunge will be be
taken away for you filming my fat ass
after Thanksgiving running into the
there will be nothing of this and I'm so
happy with that he took a picture from a
far away and I zoomed in and I went oh
my God you can still tell but yeah I I
do just and I also want to say like if
you're out there and you're pregnant or
whatever like yeah it's it's okay to
still have all of our same old body
image issues and like obviously we have
to work on them but then there's this
additional Spotlight where you're like
oh is everyone going to be like let's
see how much she gains while she's
pregnant like I I just feel that yeah
and I'm like like it's just a lot
on me and I I just really respect you
being so honest about the way you feel
about your body and like the way you're
eating I just I I really like commend
you for that I think that's cool as
because remember that moment on Tik Tok
where all of a sudden there was like all
these videos of Megan Fox actually being
honest about what she ate and we're all
like yes thank you it's not just I play
with my kids and the weight falls off
yeah yeah anyway um we unfortunately
have to wrap it up so fun but thank you
so much to our dream girl Chloe Cherry
definitely this was amazing you guys are
all so perfect angel girl on Instagram
right y um we love her we love her on
Euphoria and we love her um her diet and
and we're we're we're praying for a uh
Renaissance of that peeing in public uh
honestly what you're really going to get
is just a bunch of really sick movies
that I've been in um I've been in a
bunch of movies not like a bunch like
it's not like a hundred but it's like
five
that's we can't wait to see all the Indi
that you've beening on that's the best
that's so yeah I'm so excited cuz like
they were all just so fun to work on and
they're all going to be really good and
I think they're going to be like
Moonlight level Indies yes and
congratulations dude this is so cool and
I have more Indies planned like I have a
bunch more booked like I'm going to be
busy in 202 for shooting movies and I'm
hoping that I shoot an indie movie every
month like every other month like that's
what I'd how or like a regular movie
like any kind of movie I just want to
shoot a movie every other month for the
rest of my life or like until I'm 80 I
love it we love it we love our Indie
darling Chloe cherry and we'll see you
guys next week with a brand new
episode that's amazing so
[Music]
good
B